underwater antics all for the camera and
the woman behind the shutter is Gabby
Phi the cologne based fashion
photographer lives and works on the
French Riviera in the summer she shoots
many of her pictures in her own pool
we've had an unloved listen Maggie it's
truly magical underwater you're floating
under weightless in the war and then you
get this fabulous feeling afterwards
when you're done the results speak for
themselves when there's a lot of soul in
the picture Phi seize underwater
photography as an adventure because so
little can be planned in advance
completing a picture can take days even
months afterwards five processes the
pictures on the computer and assembles
collages of pictures
among the models she works with
frequently is unclear she dives under
water more than 20 times per day on a
shoot and can hold her breath for up to
a minute all the while still having to
look good when submerged Oscars visited
seattle it's difficult to relax with the
makeup and what you're wearing and then
to stay underwater while she takes the
pictures she needs gah beef I started
out as a model herself in the late 1970s
for 15 years of her career she worked
for German fashion label borgnar in the
1990s she moved behind the lens her
first pictures wood composite cards for
actors and models she later worked for a
variety of renowned photography agencies
five years ago she began specializing in
underwater shots what I'm an adventurer
so I wanted something different rocks
will be built I was a diver I love being
in the water I've always snorkeled I
took a diving course and then I thought
hey that will be something taking
people's pictures underwater in this
special mb enter
her most important underwater project to
date was la Senne the Last Supper it
took her half a year her picture is a
reinterpretation of Leonardo da Vinci's
work of the same name the picture is on
display at a church in Cologne damansara
Sara and Leonardo da Vinci's food we
very much had Leonardo da Vinci's
painting in mind and even copied his
frescoes on a tablecloth everything you
see in the picture is underwater we made
da Vinci's picture frame from a breaking
wave that I took underwater the table
legs everything was under water after
due to spine Alistair stumped awesome
possum all these details are essential
for garbey fine get the lighting just
right she uses a single lens reflex
camera and a high-tech flash system
setup is much like a conventional photo
studio with one important difference the
equipment is of course waterproof
when Tom's informality a dream of mine
is the Maldives I'd like to fly there
with a team of my best models open water
we'd all be in a good mood auto alone on
taking beautiful pictures underwater
with the fish and they clear water I've
worked there before and I'd really like
to go back our writers or wci gun and
off my hand but that dream is still in
the future and with summer almost over
Gaby Phi still has to wrap things up on
the French Riviera before she heads back
to Germany